investment is not trying to get money
like somebody else has made investment
is what challenges your heart God has
chosen me to put me in that position to
change the narrative to change the
people of Africa I'm not in a position
to give this order but I think I have
the authority to have the freedom of
speech and speak my mind about it it's
taking me let me hear of my life larger
skill of development
it's not just a nation Builder but the
content is valuable talking about places
and getting paid to get clamped get out
of here that was not your business I'm
telling you get out of here from the
ones who are doing it because those who
think it can't be done should not get in
the way of those who are doing it I
can't do it all but I can stop someone
[Music]
Samuel leads here in association with
freedom of speech with freedom Jacob
Caesar this dude is my mentor we're in
Ghana Africa he is absolutely changing
the nation of Africa with property
development and I'm ridiculously excited
to interview him to let you see exactly
what he's doing he started from nothing
now he's a multi multi
multi-multi-millionaire so brother
appreciate you man thank you yes
man you're changing the game bro
like I already said
you know we're building Nations
and sometimes when nations are being
built game changes yeah I don't change
the game but here I am I gotta do what I
have to do and I love what you're doing
this very moment I'm extremely excited
to be doing this black and white thing
so the the where are we right now tell
me where will we set so right now we're
sitting in number one yeah and number
one is one of my buildings
um not number two number one number one
number two is coming they should be
looking out for number two I'll do
number two number three and I keep going
because you know numbers don't end but I
keep doing it not because I want to be
more successful or be richer or be more
wealthier I just feel like there's much
room
that hasn't been developed in Africa and
I saw it as an opportunity so it's
become my great passion and my vision to
be able to fill these spaces and close
some deficits you know you're talking of
tens of millions of deficits in Africa I
can't do it all but I can stop something
you've been pretty widely picked up in
the media and the Press across Africa
particularly in Ghana for owning tigers
why do you buy Tigers why do you have
them in your house what's going down
with that well I put the two tigers for
a reason
first I wanted a black and white tiger
and I wanted a white tiger
and sometimes in life you know we
achieve a lot and we build wealth and we
think that we only have to spend it on
materials but this time I wanted to
invest in a living thing you know but I
had to find a living thing that wasn't
in West Africa not Africa and East
Africa we don't have tigers but Asians
that provide tigers or breed Tigers they
have gold they don't have gold in there
on their continent but they still have
gold they get gold they get diamonds
they get all the things from Africa so I
thought hey why can't I also get tigers
from Asia I have to get them and you
know I looked around and I had to buy
one from from South Africa the other one
I had to bid for it in Dubai with the
shake
who underestimated me because you know I
was in the bay that probably thought of
an African young kid you know he's not
gonna buy it but I paid for it and
brought it here because I want to breed
them and I want Africans to have tigers
and to add them to the animals in our
safari you know I want to bring value
tourism value to the nation it's part of
it and it's in fact it's one of the
things that I want to do in real estate
National development so I definitely
will build a zoo and build a museum
before I leave this this vanilla but
they tried to stop you from having the
Tigers in you in your house oh yeah they
did um but they failed what happened I
wouldn't say they failed but you know I
had to ask them a simple question there
first of all a tiger cannot be arrested
by a policeman
a tiger
you will need a forestry commissioner to
issue a warrant and they have to get the
appendices
from different places to be able to to
do that and of course they didn't have
it and tigers also creeped and they
crawl and they climb
so you need to have a special facility
for them plus they eat at least a car
every three days so if you don't have
the money really to feed this
animals then they're gonna eat you
and so I realized that they didn't have
the facility and you know they really
didn't have the capital to put in the in
the Tigers because as the young got to
feed them more and you have to give them
milk and you know the vets and it's a
lot of work but you know I'm happy
because the tigers they just felt like
one of my Tigers is just like number one
for me that's the values like Priceless
for me yeah I can't wait to breed I want
to give one to the president of Kenya I
want to give one to the president of
Nigeria it's just my sign of a Unity you
know saying that hey you never have this
in Nigeria take one you never have this
in Kenya and and they're the biggest in
in in the Safari business but they still
don't have tigers so I'm probably going
to give one to the president and give
one to maybe the king of of Ashanti you
know and um give one to one of my sons
that keeps playing with the Tigers even
though I warn him that they're gonna hit
you but it still keeps going and the
tide is on him so you know where was
that right now is a building that is an
award-winning building it won seven
Awards
why is this building an award-winning
building what did you do that was so
impressive with this building so I think
from the beginning of me thinking of
building this building first of all it
was quite crazy because you know I got
it from this
um
drift box thing that you know you kind
of twist it around and you have to get
all the colors on one side you know and
so that's where I got the imagination
from and I normally picked the design of
my houses from a sign you know uh I in
the beginning of my real estate business
I got into kevros and the cabros I got
it from an Evisu sign you know it's a
designer I used to wear when I was a kid
from Japan called Evisu and so I just
fell in love with the m sign and I
created a building with it by letting
the Architects do that and from then I
have to tell Architects and Engineers
what is in my mind and they have to do
it and that's the difference between me
and the others in real estate I think
they build buildings or they develop
buildings I sell spaces because I have
to create them yeah and so that's how I
created this building and I had the
smallest land
and I needed number one because I wanted
that dress to be number one Oxford so
they offered me number three I didn't
buy I had to buy number one first I do
old number two now but I had to buy
number one first and is one and a half
plot and I challenge my Architects and
my Engineers that yes put 124
cantilevers and send the rooms inside it
let's create the spaces and so I put 20
000 square meters on a thousand five
hundred square meters that's
mind-boggling so in acres how how big
was this site in a case it would be like
um a little bit over a third of my
makeup
so a third of an acre just over yeah and
it has 108 Apartments it can actually
hold maybe 300 people as family but
these are not just Apartments these are
absolutely luxury
best in the country Apartments Hotel
Apartments now that's good that brings
us to why I had to introduce these
things in the real estate because I
realized that the hotel actually
consumes 40 percent of accommodation
costs worldwide you have to remember
people stay in a hotel and they pay 300
but only for a night
that is literally someone's monthly rent
yeah okay so it makes them consume 40 of
the world's
um total contribution for accommodation
costs
and I'm the type of businessman that I
only understand numbers you know that's
how my mind works so I said wait a
minute I gotta tap into the hotel
industry but not to build a hotel I have
to be able to create something and that
will not compete with the hotel but it
would have to have the people that are
in the hotel industry have to pay
attention to me and so I came up with
the Uber homes where I said I'm gonna
design something that is
um a living room a bedroom a balcony a
closet kitchen dining work leave play do
everything presentations and everything
and I'm gonna sell it for the price of
just the hotel room
you know and and
I really
thought that I was giving too much away
for that price in the beginning and it's
been quite hard because you realize that
you know everywhere you go in the world
they give you a small room and they take
400 Euro or 400 from you and you're
selling this whole space for 250 dollars
and 300 and people still want to you
know say hey hey hey hey so for me
creating this Niche was very important
for me in the industry because I know
that given in 10 years the hotels will
start breaking their rooms and turning
it to to this sort of stuff they'll have
to yes there's no option the reason is
why because the modern world that we're
living in
people cannot live in a box anymore
yes they need their Wi-Fi which is by
far the the biggest drug right now
everybody needs it okay they need that
Wi-Fi but they need the social distance
to be able to live right you know they
want to have a privacy where the room is
and I want to be able to sit here and
have their conversation and turn on the
TV and it better be a smart solution so
they can have their presentation they
want to be able to have a cocktail in
the balcony they want to be able to have
a lifestyle they want to be able to have
some Chef come and cook for them and eat
with their friends so this spaces that
I've created can consume six to eight to
ten to 12 to 14 whatever people in one
space whereas if you talk about the
hotel room you can only bring one person
upstairs and that's probably your
girlfriend or your wife but if it's
three people coming to look for you they
have to wait for you downstairs and when
you go downstairs you have to spend
money in the bar or the restaurant so in
a way I'm saving money I'm saving energy
and I'm selling green spaces yeah and
the thing is as well if you're like me
and you've got kids got family how do
you take your kids on holiday and stay
in a hotel room
exactly you can't you need a lounge you
need a second room some of your
apartments are like three bedrooms
you've got balcony view over Accra
they're absolutely amazing so Props to
what you've done thank you very much I'm
super impressed and inspired thank you
very much I mean we started on a very
small scale and um that was 20 years ago
when I moved back from England and um
I remember I'm very spiritual and I used
to go into the land that I bought and I
used to pray all the time you know I
didn't know what to do so one day like
this voice I've been listening to since
I was a kid who just said why don't you
build two houses on
under one plot because I was supposed to
build one house
so I decided to build two houses
and that's how the maximization started
so it's become the principle today I can
build 108 apartments on just one and a
half blocks but for how I started and
has that never been done before
well it's probably
done
but
so you've made millions of pounds in
real estate however looking at your
buildings
huge buildings
all over the place I've been in them
they're luxury best in Ghana in my
opinion
where are you making your money in order
to build these buildings because this is
not cheap stuff we're talking millions
and millions of pounds how are you
getting that money because getting
getting money in Ghana it's not like
it's not like the UK where you can get
development Finance at five percent how
are you how are you financing this this
is a great question and thank you for
giving me this platform to answer this
question because a lot of people think
making money is hard working making
money is hard thinking and you see me
you got to think hard about how you
distribute the numbers now I have never
borrowed money except for the World Bank
and I just wanted to to them to borrow
money because I wanted their their batch
I wanted if any bank or any financial
institution checked on my uh track
record of developments and things that
I've done at least the World Bank has
worked with me that's all I wanted but
from the beginning I've always used the
crowdfunded I've used the things that I
sell the house and I turn into two
I turned it to fall and I risk it for a
JV that I do more than I sell then I
turn it around then I turn it around but
then I have other businesses like the
little tanka tutanka or your business
here and there I know okay I'm gonna
take this money I'm gonna put it in the
real estate I'm going to spin it around
and when it grows I'm gonna put it back
here and I'm gonna move a little bit
back here and I'm gonna sell my car too
and when I sell the car if it's eighty
thousand dollars I'm putting in the real
estate and if it comes to 160 don't be
mad at me when you see me driving a
Rolls-Royce because you know I have to
trip with the money yeah okay so it's
how you lays this investment in
development and a lot of people don't
understand investment and development
they only see credit
purchase
develop
and sales which is quite complicated for
me I will never do that you know and I
would not advise people to do that you
cannot go and borrow money to keep
building
it can take you four years and if the in
a place like Africa
if it's 13 a year
you will be at what 52 percent if your
profit is 52 you might as well give
everything to the bank you've lost so
you're getting or at least you were
getting to start building you are doing
crowdfunding and you're getting money
from investors and letting them become
Partners yeah yeah because you are going
to get at least 30 to 40 percent of your
development but people do get that money
it's just that they're not smart to use
it right you talk about how you made a
million pounds in six days which is
incredible right your first million is
always your hardest million
I want to know how you made your first
million and I wonder how old you were
when you made because I was 25 when I
made my first million oh yeah
how old were you
how old were you when you made it took
my first million pounds at the age of 21
and I tell you exactly what happened I
was living in England
and I was sent there to go to college
and I was selling fake Versace and YSL
shirts in the back of my 205 GTI which I
bought for 499 pounds my Capital when I
was going to London was six thousand
dollars my mom my brothers and everybody
gave me 130 130 pounds which they
thought it was big money for me and I
was laughing at the back of my head and
you guys must not be serious you know so
out of that six thousand dollars seven
hundred bought me a Pedro 205 GTI which
at that time was my dream car and I was
in college it was 1994 I remember very
well and I bought a Panasonic chip phone
and so I was like the new kid on the
Block then I met Johnny Prescott Johnny
Prescott was selling the jeans and the
shirts and I was just supposed to buy
one pair of jeans and one pair of shirt
but when I saw the prices 30 pounds and
20 pounds I offered him 20 pound and I
offered him 15 for the shirts and I put
them on the back of my boot and I was
selling them for 50 and 40. and so I
started making money from the boot but I
fell into the streets because I already
understood what business was at that
point business was me from where I was
coming from I'd already started making
money from a chicken farm that I created
when I was just nine years old and I
knew the value of money when you were
born into poverty you want to come out
of it it's like a disease and a curse at
the same time and if you can come out of
it that's your strength and I hope
that's strength you know and I hold it
to my chest and I hold it to my soul so
everywhere I go I need to survive and so
by the time I realized that there were
other opportunities in fact my biggest
opportunity came from a guy who climbed
my car I was a security guy in my school
and I paid him 45 pounds
to to release the club then he did it
again for the second time so I said hey
Mark is the security thing I said I'm
going to show you I'm a bad guy so I
deflate my tire took the clump put the
clump in the car saying that yes you
come and look for me this time so I took
the clamp away but my best friend at
that time was called Peter Smith and
Peter Smith was a locksmith so I went to
Peter Smith and I said you know guess
what I did today he said what I said I
stole the clump he said yeah where's the
club I said it's in my car so let me see
so he looked at it he waited and he said
I'll give you 65 quid man
so that was the beginning of my new
business what you're just getting
parking in bad places and getting paid
to get clamped and now I was getting
clumps and I was selling get out of here
that was not your business I'm telling
you get out of here like listen bro get
out of here listen so this is what led
me into Steel
so the guy got so much climbs that one
day and he said to me he said I don't
want to do I don't I don't want to sell
this anymore listen this is the guy that
buys from me it's a scrap yard I went to
the guy and he told me listen it's not
clumps it's still just any scrap that is
metal I buy I said oh no dad didn't tell
me I didn't know yeah yeah so I started
buying scraps from Savages and I will go
to the scrap yard and squash it and put
it in tracks and send it and take checks
damn so by the time I was 17 heading to
18 I was seriously into the steel
business I had grown but sometimes
people would never understand that you
know the beginning of our businesses can
always start from a bad corner you just
need to turn it around yeah and
establish it you know and I have to
confess on this but it's in my storybook
anyway so I don't mind saying it here
like you know the naked truth of Freedom
Jacob Caesar is coming from the book
that is about to come out and it's
called Freedom Jacob Caesar the rise of
the African friends it's never happened
in history there's nobody that had the
goddamn guts to wake up and say I'm the
Prince of a continent I did because I
claim it yeah and I wear the crown and
I've been in the street and I've been in
the corporate world I've claimed all the
titles but it doesn't show in my face
neither does this show in my skin you
need to be inside me to know and that's
my soul nobody touches it I'm the new
one I'm the new one to inspire motivate
the youth I'm here to share my story
with them not only they still made me a
million though
but I met a guy called samurai from
American communication Network that
introduced me to telecommunications and
that's when the checks started growing
so by the time I was 21 I had a million
and 79 000 pounds and some women and I
just had my son my first son
and some women in the bank liked me
because I always carried my son and came
to the bank and deposit checks and then
after I go to the telephone banking and
I press one and I ask five questions the
next day when I go I pressed two and ax
question so that's how I studied banking
when did you get into real estate oh I
got into real estate when I came to
Africa and it was by accident like when
I was a kid this very building right
there okay
um I used to come to I used to go to a
nightclub there so when I came back I
went to rent a place and turned into a
nightclub I didn't do the nightclub
because I wanted a nightclub but I was
bored I was the only one here and I had
to invite people to come to Ghana
you know from other parts of the world
so it was like a movement and I I did
that when I did that I made seventy five
thousand dollars
in three weeks I took everybody's money
from their pocket they were buying
champagne and Hennessy and then when I
finished taking their money they started
buying Alize so that means the money had
gone down I closed the club and I
convinced the woman to sell me the
building when they saw me the building
in two months someone offered me 150 000
for it I bought the building for 75 000.
so I made 75 000 for the profit of the
building but I also made 75 000 from the
nightclub yeah and I had to wait it too
you know I was like okay the nightclub
took me like three weeks I was changing
money into Dollars this was one check
and it cleared yeah so I said you know
what I'm gonna go into real estate I
don't want to be a nightclub owner so
that's what I started and then and then
I went for the second building that I
told you I made 300 000 profits over
like you know like that yeah yeah and so
I started real estate bye
selling buying and selling yes before I
use the money to buy a land and stuff I
think it's real estate is a business
right like any business you have
customers your guests or your tenants or
your customers yeah right so you were
doing steel business telecommunications
business what was it that made you
really focus because now I imagine that
you make nearly all of your money in
real estate yeah so I
at that time when I had the million
pounds okay I was supposed to pay I was
bound to pay a tax
you know in England
and I had to either invest the money or
I paid the tax and it would have been
like 179 000 pounds so I invested the
money in Hawaii in a tick Farm
okay and I came to Ghana with 20 000
pounds that's how I started my husband
and did the nightclub and bought the
building and started so within four
years I made million again yeah okay and
I started using that to build the real
estate Empire and five years after I got
offered 5.5 million pounds for my tea
Farm
it was supposed to yield in seven years
this guy wanted to buy it before even
the seven years and I was so shocked I
never understood the value of investment
at that time when I put the 1 million I
even sometimes thought I had lost it so
this is how I understood the investment
you know investment is not trying to get
money like somebody else have made
investment is what challenges your heart
your soul and the risk that you want to
take that a million or a billion cannot
take and you go for it that's investment
yeah you know it's like what a million
can't do to care for somebody you go for
it that's investment what's your
motivation what what motivates you to go
and build these buildings well I just
think that how I started you know I was
climbing and when I realized that you
know those who can climb the furthest to
the furthest point are those who are not
scared to fall from hardier climate yeah
a lot of people are looking how they're
gonna fall you know and so I lost my
fear along the way and he courage took
over me yeah and I kept going and I was
like okay I'm not gonna look at anyone
they're not gonna like me but you know
what I'm gonna have to make them like me
when I finish yeah and that's what has
been happening you know what's your
message to
people of Africa wanting to get welfare
be inspired by the likes of yourself
what is it that's holding people back
what is it that keeps people trapped or
enslaved in poverty because you started
doing nothing you've built a huge Empire
how how what's your advice and words of
encouragement and wisdom to people
getting started well I think first of
all Africans need to get rid of the
disease that has infiltrated the
inhabitants of the continent and that is
fear
you know you can't be too scared of what
you dream of
you know you can't be scared of your own
vision
you can't be scared of thinking higher
thinking smart
you know thinking excessively there is
nothing to lose you know it costs you
nothing to congratulate someone
it costs you zero percent to say thank
you and it costs you zero percent for
you to say I'm going up there it's just
about a will and a power that you need
to make so they need to get rid of the
fear and they need to start having hope
because yesterday might have not been
good
but today
is borrowed to you and tomorrow is not
promised God damn it we all have nothing
to lose we just have to do what we think
we can do what we're capable of doing
and it might not be the doing of doing
that I'm doing but
this doing can impact somebody can
change someone's life can motivate or
Inspire somebody it doesn't matter what
you're doing but you have to get rid of
that fear I think it's a big disease
it's killing Africans from the ministers
to the government to the president to
the mothers to the fathers to the
sisters like these guys are scared it's
just the pulling down syndromes it's not
how did you get the money where did you
come from who are you this that that hey
if you're scared how come you got so
much questions to ask yeah don't ask the
questions learn from the ones who are
doing it because those who think it
can't be done should not get in the way
of those who are doing it those who are
doing it are doing it because that's
what they're used to doing yeah okay and
these guys are scared they have too much
fear in them and I I'm not here to say
that oh I'm the king Khan I'm the
president to save you or I'm the
government I'm here to tell you the
facts that look the fear is a disease
it's going to kill you yeah it's really
going to kill you and it's going to kill
your soul and it's going to kill your
dream and that means your Dead Man
Walking
so forget trying to be rich
because you've seen someone successful
or wealthy if you have that fear in you
you can never get there because when I
was climbing this
ah no fear
and I'm still climbing right now I'm not
scared too far you know why because I
simply know how to climb back up yeah
okay absolutely I've got the template
absolutely okay I've got the template
and and that's what you need yeah like
God likes people with Courage the
universe supports people who are bold
yeah the universe is behind Malcolm X
the universe is behind uh Rockefeller
because Rockefeller said there is oil
there and I have to drill it and he kept
Drilling and Drilling and when he found
the oil he built the Standard Oil and
when he got the Standard Oil he ruled
for so long for so long some people
think you are the president of Ghana and
people stop you all the world when we
just pulled up into the hotel there was
a guy I think you thought he was my
employee I thought he was your employee
but he was actually just a dude of a
camera that was filming our entire
conversation
what happened well I don't know where
this came from because all of a sudden
people started saying the president
president and the youth and all of that
you know
I don't know anything about politics
honestly
um like I tell people I don't even know
how to become an assemblyman I don't
know the ways to become that
and it's not like
it's not like
I don't want to understand politics but
I think The Narrative of politics when
it comes to Africa is a little bit
sensitive to the way I proceed and
perceive things now why so because you
know I I think when I look at the
Western uh platforms for politics
political platforms which I would say
Democratic Democratic platforms now you
see that these people actually go to the
public and show the public what they
want to do and what they want to become
and the public donates to them and
supports them and in they lift their
hands for them but when you come to
Africa they actual flag bearers go to
the public and bribe them yeah you know
to become a leader and I think it's so
biased and it's
it's not right I feel like you know it
should be changed I like I'm not I'm not
in a position to give this order but I
think I have the authority to have the
freedom of speech and speak my mind
about it right I think that you know if
you ever saw me as that person it's
because God has chosen me to put me in
that position to change the narrative to
change the people of Africa because
there has to be that leader they've been
gone since the 1960s and I live with the
spirit to me the spirits of Malcolm X
Martin Luther
Mansa Musa the spirits of hey salasi
Kwame and chroma Visionaries they're all
in me I don't know where I adopted it
from but that's how I think I think
industrial I think revolutional I think
of development I think of investment and
I think that the world deserves a
funding to be given to them the Nations
the people you know you have to leave
some value behind you know yeah when
you're not there you know your
investment is just not your houses or
the cars or the Tigers you have but your
investment becomes what you left with
people that is moving to feed forward
and that's what I stand for the Freedom
Movement that's great how many how many
members of Staff do you have
any work for you at the moment I work
with about 220 people but that's just in
Ghana outside Ghana I have different
workers you know our real estate is very
far it it goes very further you know we
start stuff in La you can look at um
selling Sunset
um episode I think series three episode
five yeah it's got one of the one of my
buildings there in in LA right in Bel
Air you know um and and we did some
stuff with Versace there and you know
it's kind of crazy it's it's one of the
best it came even on Channel 5 in
England you know doing very well talking
about the best five homes in the world
and you know funny enough to pick one of
my houses and if you're doing stuff in
Nigeria which I'm about to take you down
to let you see on a module what I really
do I think
I think I'm crazy but you know what I
don't mind being crazy because if this
is what craziness is
then people better be crazy because if
you really know you're crazy and you're
moving then you're doing something that
will really surprise people in this
world but when I look at the things I'm
doing it's quite a lot and I move with
courage with boldness I take a heavy
step you know I Venture heavily and I'm
always successful with it and we're in
Nigeria now I haven't come to England
because I'll probably just buy a house
there I do have a family house in a nice
bridge but I grew up in happy you know
and I live in central London whenever
I'm in England I haven't seen anything
that I want to do in England yet I
haven't seen anything I want to do what
do you think of what I'm doing in
England you've seen my developments you
know what I'm doing I love that and I
think that for your age you know I see
myself in you like I want this for
people for young people because the
people of today think that you know they
have time to get rich or to become
successful to become wealthy you know
you've got to be you've got to be doing
it now if you're 15 and you're not you
don't know what you're gonna do by 20
and if you're in your 20s and you're not
seeing some Millions you're going to
have a problem with all this Facebook
and Instagram and watches and protect
the leaves and jeeps and rolls royces
and this and that with kids driving it
hey you're going to go crazy if you
don't work and think hard it's so I'm
very proud of you with what you're doing
in real estate means the realest State
yeah what do you mean by that what do
you mean so so basically there are three
rules in real estate okay rule number
one location rule number two location
rule number three location so it's
location location location one is
supposed to be there one is supposed to
be the landmark one is supposed to be
tailored to the audience so the
patronize okay so it's all about the
location location that location creates
a state
so a space and a state on it yeah but
the ones that are very expensive
is in the real estate so it's a real
estate when you put the words together
the ones that's great yeah and
everybody's in real estate really if you
look at the sometimes which list or you
look at all the wealthy people the
billionaires they're all investing in
real estate pretty much it's better than
putting your money in the bank come to
think about it yeah you know because if
there is war right now
in your country or anyone else's country
they might just run away trying to get
to other countries okay the bank
the systems in the bank can be shut
you run to England and you put your card
in a machine
yeah that money is gone not
the war can go on for five years ten
years and you come back your building
might have gunpowder smoke and
everything on it but it's still sitting
there yeah it can't be moved exactly and
the ownership still stays the same so
for me I think acquisition for Real
Estate is great but a lot of people have
misunderstood real estate for like some
sort of competitive business where they
just want to do what others are doing
because they've seen them get rich that
also you can be swallowed because the
real estate you can put your money on a
land that will be growing one percent
every five years
interesting and I know we've been
talking a lot about we've been spending
the day together looking at different
sites how do you how do you know how do
you weigh up that this is the right deal
because there's there's so many
opportunities I'm I'm investing right
now you know I've been talking to you
about
investing in Ghana and there's just
endless opportunities how do you how do
you know when a good deal is a good deal
because you know
I'm going to share this trick with you
opportunities are not found neither are
they discovered
opportunities are sensed or smelled
a lot of people are looking for it to
grab it it's like money you know you're
looking for it where you can't see it
you either work for it or you sweat for
it or you do something for it you have
to put an exchange for it and that's
opportunities there's so many things
that looks like looks opportunistic but
it's only a few of them that can really
become lucrative
and that's where you need to have that
great third eye to be able to have that
foresight yeah what would sell you know
even at the time when you are investing
and I I thank God like I feel like I
have that skill even if you put me in
China two years by the time you come
back you see the same Freedom doing what
I do here too do you think people in
Ghana and Africa are waking up to the
fact that you can make money be
entrepreneurs invest in real estate I
mean you know I'm getting stocked and
gone all the time by people that have
been watching me on YouTube and have
been inspired and are wanting to do
stuff
in fact you're you're you've got a
member of staff
who went on my training program yeah
yeah my nephew actually told me about
you yeah and you know he went on your
training program and he learned uh rent
to rent and all of this and you know I
came to pick him from London and brought
him here today he is my executive
assistant for the group and my group is
like not just real estate you know we
Diversified in many things and I think I
will open up more to you this
um this interview is just the beginning
yeah you're about to find out about the
biggest projects that is going on in the
real estate here's what I want to tell
you that what you're doing is great that
educational thing that you did for all
you're doing for people to understand
how real estate is conducted and how
real estate is
sort of orchestrated when you have to
establish it it's such a great value
you're giving back to society and I like
to encourage you to keep doing that I
appreciate it because yeah you're
putting value in the youth and you're
reminding them that you got to get
successful you have to become successful
at a younger age and I like that that's
why I'm sitting here I can't believe I
was 25 before I made my first million
how slow can you get I told you like
maybe yeah
but you know for the people that
you are
impacting right now
they're probably in their 30s
and they're trying to think how they can
stop like you yeah so you are their
Mentor they're looking up to you you
know you are starting something great
never never have any fear to brunch you
can make and build wealth on any land
the safest place mostly is where you
come from not because it makes a lot of
sense but it's because there is
sometimes a great spirit behind you when
you invest on your own land yeah you
know you have your family around you
have the people who can relate to you
around yeah you know and you can create
wealth from where you belong to and let
it start to spike out well to other
places and I think that's why I'm
getting to you know I'm getting to the
point where I feel like very soon the
world have no choice they're gonna have
to pay me
you know I don't know how but I see it
and I feel it coming you know when I
look at all the other things that I'm
very much interested in in doing you
know I feel it and I know it's coming
and I know that very soon if people have
to come to Africa and look for a
different type of opportunity is because
I've proven to the world that the wealth
that is here is enormous it's endless if
we have to create it ourselves yeah and
that's a great example that I want to
set for Society for Humanity I belong to
a race that is far behind a race and
that is mostly disregarded why because
their mindset is still undermined by
their own
you know and uh they haven't been able
to get yourself out of that position
that situation so
we might have a fast-growing economy but
when it comes to development we're
running behind schedule and when I talk
about development I'm talking on Social
Development human development yeah and
these two things are great things to
keep the nature going I think that we
haven't crossed that border yet you know
I want to be one of the first people in
that to move the rest of the world the
rest of the people their feet forward
you know I I feel like that's part of my
legacy that's part of my responsibility
you know it's not just going to be just
real estate it's about Building Wealth
for the Youth and adding value to a
society and making sure that I impact
this continent before I leave here I see
myself as the nurse leader not the
president not a tyrant but a leader a
leader that has a rulers instant
education
that's what I do I dictate to my
Architects to my Engineers to my workers
and when they follow my lead we come out
with something that is especially
tailored to the human demands amazing
[Music]